case
I can only say how troubling it was to
see Evan an innocent journalist held in
these circumstances
I was able to meet Evan yesterday at La
fortiva prison
it was the first time we were granted
Consular access since his wrongful
detention more than two weeks ago
I can report that he is in good health
and remain strong despite his
circumstances
we will continue to provide an
all-appropriate support to Evan and his
family and we expect Russian authorities
to provide continued Consular access to
Evan
the charges against Evan are baseless
and we call on the Russian Federation to
immediately release him
we also call for the immediate release
of Paul Whalen
Paul has been held more than four years
in Russia
both men deserve to go home to their
families now thank you